If your website or brand does not show
up in AI search mentions or you don't
have any chat GPT perplexity or AI
search mentions, then here is a 2-minute
fix that you can implement. Google Page
Speed Insights just launched a new
feature that tells you whether or not
your website is ready to be scraped and
understood by AI search engines. It's
called the agentic browsing. And in
today's video, I'll be explaining what
this is and I'll be showing you how to
go from a one or zero out of three to a
three out of three on your website.
Let's go ahead and get started. So,
first let's talk about what exactly is
this new update. So, it's a fifth
category that Google added in May of
2026. It measures something none of the
others touch, how easily an AI agent can
read your page, understand it, and act
on it without a human driving. So,
essentially,
how easily can an AI read your website,
use your
your sort of checkout pages, or use your
forms,
interact with your website. And if you
can use it better, and if you can
understand your website better, then
naturally AI agents and AI bots will
mention your website in ChatGPT,
Perplexity, Claude, and so on. So, here
is how it works. It's not a score out of
100, it's a score out of three. You're
going to get either a pass, you're going
to get a fail, or not applicable. So, if
you scroll down here to this website
that has a one out of three, we can see
here that number one, it's failing.
Number two, it's failing. And number
three, it's passing. So, it obviously
has a one out of three.
So, what exactly does agentic browsing
measure? It measures your accessibility
tree, number one. And your accessibility
tree is a stripped-down structured map
of your page. So, the same one screen
readers use. Agents read this instead of
your raw HTML or a screenshot because
it's cleaner and cheaper to progress.
A cheaper to process. So, it's a
stripped-down structured map of your
page. Second is your cumulative layout
shift, which is the same visibility
metric from Core Web Vitals. Number
three is your LLM's.txt
file. The file at your domain root, it's
a short markdown summary of what your
site is and links to its key pages
written for LLM's. It's the equivalent
of having your robots.txt
or your sitemap.xml.
It's a curated overview, so an agent
doesn't have to crawl the whole site to
figure out what you do, right? So, you
want to put everything what you do and
all of your top pages in a markdown file
and submit it as your LLM's.txt
file. And lastly, something that's new,
emerging, and is experimental, it's a
web MCP checks. So, essentially, it's a
proposed standard that lets a site hand
agents a labeled set of actions. Instead
of the agent guessing from what the
visual layout is, you give them a
labeled set of actions such as submit
this form after cart, but you need to
have a specific Chrome extension and a
trial account. So, right now, it is not
applicable, right? But, you can see here
that it does consider adding your web
MCP annotations to the form listed
below. This helps the AI agents identify
and interact with these forms more
reliably. So, essentially, again, you
can add these web MCPs onto forms, onto
tools, um to schemas as well, so that
the AI agents will understand the
information a little bit better. So, how
do you go from a one out of three to a
three out of three for agentic browsing?
We're actually in the process of
building a website builder, which allows
you to create websites out of the box
that are GEO and SEO optimized with
in-depth content, but we wanted to make
it a little bit more easier to use. So,
essentially, this builder is already
going to have every single website that
it uses, it's already going to have it
LLM.txt, robots.txt,
sitemap, and other SEO and GEO
optimization from the get-go. So, all
you do is you enter in inputs about your
website, and then we build out the
website for you. We build out the
service pages, the category pages, the
site structure, location pages, um and
then you can just generate that uh
easily using AI. So, we generate full
in-depth pages, not, you know, thin uh
general content. You can also automate
your blog creation. We also have
automated blogging sequences, which
allow you to do keyword research and
then set up blog automations, and you
can connect it with Word Rocket in the
future. But, as you can see, these pages
are very, very in-depth, right? Um the
website is very beautifully built, but
most importantly, this is the exact same
site that we tested in Google PageSpeed
Insights, and we have a 95+ on all
performance metrics, and we have a three
out of three browsing. So, the sites
will be SEO and GEO ready to help you
get cited, picked up by AI, and rank on
Google out of the box. All you have to
do is customize it for your specific
niche. This tool is in very early beta
access, so if you want to get access to
it, there will be a link below where you
can click and request access, and we'll
be sending out access periodically over
the next week as we continue to build
this out. Also, if you want to get my
full prompt that you can just pop into
Claude and then do your PageSpeed
Insights and pop in whatever your
results are for Agentic browsing. It
will then tell you what to do to fix
these issues and get a three out of
three. Comment Agentic below and I'll
send it over to you. Hope that you guys
enjoyed today's video. I'll see you in
the next one. Take care.